well we now know that Republicans have
won the house in the 2022 midterms and
will control the House of
Representatives for a two-year period it
will be Hunter Biden 24 7. it may be Joe
Biden impeachment how do we know well
I'll show you in a moment if you needed
any more sense of what to expect though
you need look only over to the Senate
and what 37 Republican Senators there
did in voting against recognizing
codifying same-sex and interracial
marriages it's 2022. it's not 2002 or
1992 or 1922 but 37 Republican Senators
said let's not codify federal
recognition of same-sex and interracial
marriage and that tells us a lot about
what we can expect in the house now one
important thing to mention at the end of
the day
we had shifting forecasts uh polls being
molded like putty we didn't know well as
which scenario the most likely scenario
going into the midterms was Democrats
hold the Senate but lose the house and
that's exactly what happened now of
course it was a circuitous path to get
there but the final result
in the 30 000 foot view is exactly what
we expected now in terms of the Biden
impeachment
Hunter Biden investigations these are
really not maybes first and foremost Jim
Jordan will become chair of the house
Judiciary Committee when this new
Congress is sworn in a disgrace a
humiliation but a very clear sign of
what is to come because we know all
about Jim Jordan's interests in
irrelevant stories like Hunter Biden
secondly we are going to see people like
Marjorie Taylor green now spend two
years trying to impeach Biden probably
three or four times a week and the Hope
has to be that the American people
overall and you know when there are so
many people who have been successfully
targeted by weaponized propaganda that
they will believe that impeaching Biden
and investigating Hunter Biden make
sense as judicial prior legislative
priorities House of Representatives
priorities but the Hope has to be that
most people realize investigating Hunter
Biden does nothing for me about
inflation or wages or health care or
whatever the case may be
um many of us saw this coming there's no
question about it but it is now
abundantly clear that it is going to be
Hunter Biden 24 7. just as a couple of
examples for you
over on Twitter the House GOP Twitter
account has spent much of the last 24
hours uh tweeting about Hunter Biden and
as you scroll down and look at the
things here Joe Biden is the big guy
they tweeted big guy is a reference to a
hunter Biden story in which they say Joe
Biden is referred to as the big guy
who's getting a cut of something you
know these conspiracy theories that they
have they then posted a clip of an
interview with Hunter Biden again
they're obsessed with Hunter Biden then
before that this is all in the last hour
by the way as I'm filming then they
posted a link to a Fox News article
about Hunter Biden then they posted a
picture of Joe Biden allegedly meeting
Hunter Biden's Kazakh business associate
then previously they had posted another
clip from an interview with Hunter Biden
and more pictures of the Biden family I
I'm not going to waste the entire
segment talking about this but going on
and on and on and then by the way this
morning a Fox News covered a press
conference in which Republican
Congressman James Comer
declared that the hunter Biden uh that
Hunter Biden himself is going to be at
the center of Investigations to be
carried out by the Republican house so
there's two ways to look at this one
these people are obsessed
with uh Joe and Hunter Biden in a way
that makes no sense Hunter Biden's not
an elected official he's not running for
anything he has nothing to do with the
administration contrary to Ivanka and
Jared who did have things to do with the
Trump Administration the people are
going to see through it and they're not
going to go for it the Counterpoint
would be hey Republicans have a solution
to just about every problem inflation
well we're going to subpoena Hunter
Biden gas prices are too high subpoena
Hunter Biden what do we do about housing
or China or health care or immigration
or whatever police we're investigating
Hunter Biden and maybe we're even
impeaching Joe Biden will much of the
country fall for it
I don't know I don't know now if we want
to put
the best possible spin on this and by
this I mean Republicans taking the house
making it clear they're going to spend
two years mostly focused on Hunter Biden
this is going to be
the slimmest of slim majorities for
republicans in the house and you could
make the case that this will expose
their
BS their obsession with the relevant
things like Hunter Biden such that in
2024
it will be very helpful to Democrats in
taking back a sizable majority
that's the the sort of rose-colored
glasses view on this they'll have just
enough power to look bad but hopefully
not enough power to cause major
destruction I don't know it's really a
predictive question and as I've told you
before humans are pretty bad at making
predictions the upshot of the obsession
with the hunter Biden stuff is yeah Fox
News is going to talk about it all the
time but I don't think the American
people generally speaking are obsessed
with Hunter at all it's a sliver of the
right that cares about Hunter and so
we'll see where it all shakes out
we have now a little bit of data to
maybe answer the question could
disproportionate Republican coveted
deaths have flipped any particular seats
in the 2022 midterms now let me reset
this for you because we've talked about
this probably for a year or more but now
we're really in the thick of it because
we now have most of the results of the
2022 midterms we know that more
Republicans than Democrats died of covet
we don't know exactly to what degree or
by how much but we know that this is a
result of early on in the pandemic
Republicans were less likely to heed
public safety guidelines than were
Democrats therefore they got more
coveted and as a function of that more
of them died
in the post-vaccine era uptake of
vaccines was lower among Republicans
than it was among Democrats and as a
result of that more Republicans died of
covid generally speaking and so the
question of whether this impacted the
election results is really a
mathematical question first you've got
to figure out to what degree were
Republicans dying of covet more than
Democrats it seems like now it's it's
twice as much so we could call it two to
one J you could zoom out and say okay
twice as much means roughly
two-thirds of the coveted deaths were
Republicans one-third of the coveted
deaths were Democrats got about a
million deaths okay so again we're very
much zooming out when a 12 year old dies
you don't assign a party affiliation to
that right but we're speaking super
generally
out of a million you would say well
that's like 666 000 Republican deaths
333 000 Democratic deaths again these
aren't real numbers because you've also
got non-voters in there and kids Etc
that means that the Gap means about 333
000 more Republicans than Democrats died
assuming everybody is a voter and is an
adult so then you've got to figure out
of that 333 000 Gap are there any
particular districts where the Gap alone
or any particular States for Statewide
Senate and gubernatorial elections where
that death difference alone could have
flipped a seat we don't really know the
answer yet but it's increasingly being
studied
um we uh there is a well actually Vice
wrote this up and they are not the
authors of the study but we'll link to
this article the study is called excess
death rates for republicans and
Democrats during the covid-19 pandemic
and they looked at death records They
looked at voter registration and they
said what is the link here between
political affiliation covet deaths and
the impact on the midterms now I am
going to come out and and right up front
say a couple different things
it is completely possible that the
margins here
were between Republican and Democratic
deaths in particular congressional
districts for example weren't actually
big enough to really flip any elections
maybe they were maybe they were not
there are some who are saying that it is
just filthy to even be asking this
question I completely disagree with that
um you're you're not making Light Of
Anything by on top of all of the obvious
personal and family tragedy that our
covet deaths to ask the political
question and say could this have shaped
the electorate in 2022 it's a completely
reasonable question to ask so don't
don't be swayed by the Republicans who
are turning up their noses and saying
how offensive how offensive to even ask
the question there's really nothing
wrong with asking the question the next
part of this is it would be interesting
to actually get some some specific
numbers you know we
in the lead up to 2022 I used an example
from Florida's last gubernatorial
election and in Florida's last
gubernatorial election the margin
between Ron DeSantis and then Democratic
candidate Andrew Gillum was very small
and based on that margin
the disproportionate Republican covet
deaths in Florida could have made a
difference but that was in the last
election the margin was so big in
DeSantis defeating Charlie Crist uh last
week that the covet deaths would not
make a difference it was a 19 Point uh
win for Ron DeSantis so the theoretical
example I gave about Florida from the
previous election it really doesn't
apply because the margin was so big so
generally speaking
even if there were no specific races
that depended on the partisan split in
Cova deaths this may become a larger
component of Republican demographics
related to vaccines Beyond covid given
the growing anti-vaccine sentiment that
is developed in the Republican Party
since covid more broadly we might
actually start to see this particularly
over time be a factor you know we've
said before there are demographic
changes happening in Texas where Texas
is becoming a Bluer as a result of
demographic changes there may also be
changes to the electorate forced in by
anti-vaccine sentiment it shouldn't come
as a huge shock that this is sort of the
conclusion to what has been quite
frankly Decades of Republicans
increasingly denying science
increasingly telling themselves
scientists are just sort of like liberal
professors you can ignore everything
they say and bring your own opinion and
your own opinion is just as valid as
theirs
seeing that grow for decades should then
not make a surprise now at what we are
seeing at some point we will probably
get a more specific answer was there any
particular race that arguably was
flipped by disproportionate Republican
covet deaths we don't have the answer
right now but it is being studied
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show is an audience
supported program we do an extra show
every single day called the bonus show
just for our members we also provide an
audio and video feed of every show
commercial free published about five or
six hours before the entire show is
published you can get access to all of
that at joinpakman.com and you can also
use the coupon code 24 starts now to get
yourself a nice little discount that's
all at joinpakman.com I would love for
you to sign up and support the work that
we do Mike Pence malfunctioned at a
completely cringe-worthy town hall on
CNN last night this is absolutely beyond
belief former vice president Mike Pence
had a really bad town hall on CNN last
night in which he among other things got
a lady's name wrong and then just went
silent for five seconds uh really really
odd the the bigger question is why why
he's even doing Town Halls on CNN right
now you might say well it's because he's
maybe running in 24 maybe right now the
predictive markets don't look very good
for Mike Pence so check out this clip
this is one of the wildest Clips I've
seen
a lady named Andrea asks a question and
Penn's call Pence calls her Barbara and
then it gets really weird and Pence
appears to malfunction now I admit I
watched this about 10 times last night I
was laughing so hard to myself I almost
woke up my sleeping baby daughter check
this out now the the Andrea's last name
is Barbara Dansby so Barbara wasn't
completely pulled out of thin air but
her name isn't Barbara it's Andrea when
Andrea corrects Mike Pence he he sort of
seems to freeze and glitch it was almost
trump-like check this out and this
Freedom based on Roe also continue
Barbara thank you I represented Madison
County in Congress for many years Andrea
it's nice to see you
that that pause was not I did I did
nothing to doctor that uh very very
strange pause
this is a kafka-esque moment I I know I
know it's been months since I brought
out kafka-esque this is unbelievable
Barbara thank you that my name's Andrea
good to see you and then he says nothing
I am let's just just take it in one more
time for its full cringe-worthy glory in
this Freedom based on Roe also continue
Barbara thank you I represented Madison
County in Congress for many years Andrea
it's nice to see you
you know when I oh dear God okay so it
was only downhill from there if you can
imagine that wasn't even the worst
moment so the first actual question that
Penn Scott it was such a softball that I
thought this was all going to be a waste
of time look look at how soft this
question is whether you love him or hate
him yeah former president Trump now
candidate Trump is a polarizing figure
who brought controversial issues to the
Forefront of American politics
how does the country move past the
polarization and find Common Ground
solutions to these important issues
facing this nation I mean it's Pence's
answer doesn't even matter that's the
prototypical softball question and of
course Pence has no idea how to bring
the country together he's part of the
Evangelical right-wing movement that has
sowed division in the country for
decades it Pence is completely uh
unqualified to answer the question but
so soft but then it actually got kind of
interesting CNN actually showed video
showed Pence video of The Gallows where
Trump supporters wanted to hang Pence on
January 6. now Pence has developed a a
sort of um demeanor during these moments
where he will sort of like pause and act
like he's thinking very deeply and it's
very you know important what to say it's
all contrived but it's still interesting
to confront him with this video check
this out on a um take you back to that
day take a look at the video over here
um that of course was the news hanging
outside the capitol that day and rioters
were calling for your execution uh
chanting hang Mike Pence almost two
years later is it still tough to there's
some of the video of the Hang Mike Pence
two years later
is it still tough to see that and hear
that
he's thinking now
Jake it it saddens me sad
but that day it angered me
yeah I must tell you when uh
oh
when the Secret Service took us down to
the loading dock accompanied by my wife
my daughter Charlotte and our secret
service detail
I was determined to stay at my post I
told the Secret Service that I was not
leaving the Capitol
I didn't want to give those people the
sight of a 16 car motorcade speeding
away from the capitol that day right
but frankly when I saw those images
and when
when I read a tweet that President Trump
issued
I'm saying that I lack courage in that
moment
it angered me greatly
but to be honest with you I didn't have
time for it
yeah
um it's all just very strange and I get
the idea
that what Pence is trying to do here is
sort of like project strength and calm
and an unwavering demeanor but at the
same time it all continues to be sort of
like you realize the guy you worked for
almost got you killed right I mean that
literally almost in the sense that of
course he had Secret Service protection
but his followers wanted you dead this
wasn't Democrats this was your side and
then at another point the town hall
almost gets like an intervention type
vibe
if I were you I would still be livid
with Donald Trump
I would be so Furious
and I know you're a measured man right
um but are you still angry
well I must tell you the president's
words and tweet that day were Reckless
they endangered my family and
and all the people at the Capitol
and I was angry
but you know my Christian faith tells me
to be quick to listen
slow to speak and slow to become angry
all right so then he just goes into
Christian stuff and says you know we
forgive and so on and so forth so the
question why was he doing this at all I
don't really know the answer the betting
Market's now on the question of who will
win the 2024 Republican nomination have
this quite frankly as just a race
between Rhonda sandis and Donald Trump
and Mike Pence is sort of like in a tied
for third position alongside Nikki Haley
and Glenn youngin so what this means for
the future of Pence I don't really know
but it was certainly interesting to hear
where his head was yesterday uh and it's
all very very strange and uh remains to
be seen whether Pence will actually run
but but very very he's just a strange
guy I think at the end of the day of the
day is what I'm realizing he also
appeared on Fox News let's take a look
at that appearance real quick I'm not
going to spend a ton of time on this but
Mike Pence has put together a number of
appearances here
um connected of course to the book that
he has written and he
you know he's turned on Trump he's
abandoned Trump Pence has put together a
list of five or so very calculated
statements that he repeats one that
we've heard often is what Trump did was
Reckless on January 6th another one that
he repeats is he endangered my family
these are not accidents these are
workshopped lines where Pence knows he's
going to get these questions and he
works with a team to figure out here's
the things I'm going to say a new thing
that he said yesterday on Fox News was
that there will be better choices for
the Republican nomination in 2024 than
Trump and one of the most interesting
things about this is watching the Fox
Fox and Friends hosts figure out how to
deal with this I honestly believe that
uh we'll have better choices come 2024
you know I don't think anybody's than
Donald Trump I do yeah we will have
better choices than Donald Trump
so the question Still Remains of course
if the nominee in 24 is Donald Trump
will you vote vote for him I have no
reason right now to believe that the
answer is no I think much like William
Barr who criticized Trump up and down
for a dozen different things and then
when it came to well but would you vote
for him if he's the nominee and he's
like well yeah Democrats are a disaster
I'm not voting for a Democrat I think
despite all this despite Pence's anger
that Trump endangered his family
he still hasn't said if Trump is the
nominee I will not vote for him and I
think that he will
um one other interesting anecdote from
yesterday's interview with Fox
um he talked about I get my
understanding is this is the last time
he spoke to Trump and I went into his
office and uh
I I after he made inquiries about Karen
and Charlotte who'd been with me at the
Capitol the entire time on January 6 all
the way until four in the morning yeah
um he asked me uh he asked me what I
felt that day and I told him I was angry
we had our differences and
seeing those people ransacking the
capital infuriated me I
my my only thought was not this not here
not in America right but we I was very
candid with him we were very
straightforward with each other I I
sensed in the president as I write it
genuine remorse about what had happened
in the days that followed that
we spoke again and again in the two
weeks remaining of the administration
what's funny about I sense genuine
remorses as recently as last month or
two weeks ago Trump made clear he
doesn't have remorse he repeated all the
same stuff that infuriated his followers
about Mike Pence I I also Trump has
never expressed remorse about anything
none of this all seems made up
but on that day that you ask about
um
I sense the president was still
saddened by what had occurred
and I just reminded him as I had at the
beginning of our first conversation that
I was praying for
I prayed for that President almost every
day during our Administration
and he was dismissive about it at first
don't don't bother but then as I a few
minutes later as I got up to leave the
room I looked at him as he sat at the
end of the little table in the dining
room just off the Oval Office
and I said well I guess there's just two
things we're probably always going to
disagree on
and he looked up at me and
faintly said what and I said refer to my
role on January 6.
and then I said
I'm never going to stop praying for you
and he looked at me and
said that's right don't don't ever
change yeah and we parted amicably does
anybody believe that story and and the
the biggest lie seems to be the last
thing we parted amicably Trump doesn't
part amicably with people he just
doesn't but I don't believe a word of
that story so it's an interesting
anecdote because it's the opposite of
everything that we know Trump to be he
wants to sell books we'll see what
happens in 2024. hey one quick note
Madison cawthorne thankfully as one of
the most radical members of Congress to
be elected in 2020 was defeated in a
Republican primary
good he'll be leaving on January
whatever the date is uh 2023 when the
new Congress is inaugurated except it
appears that he has already left there's
a very interesting report from The
Citizen Times uh Madison cawthorne
vacates offices before end of term
constituents calls go unanswered he has
stopped working Madison cawthorne is no
longer working he's still an elected
official he's still a member of Congress
he isn't working anymore and this is
just really instructive about what
happens when you vote for these people
none of these people want to work this
is the exact same story as what we saw
with Donald Trump during the campaign
over the summer in 2020 Trump by many
reports had essentially stopped all
presidential duties he wasn't receiving
the presidential daily briefing
even when he was receiving it he wasn't
really paying attention but he wasn't
even ostensibly receiving it
um and then in the period between the
November 2020 election and when Trump
ultimately left the White House he
wasn't doing any work these people don't
actually want to work they don't want to
work Madison cawthorne has just left he
has abandoned the job that quite frankly
he was never actually interested in
doing it was sort of like it was sort of
like college right he thought this
sounds kind of cool but he didn't
actually want to do the stuff that's
required people around him were a little
bit creeped out he did a terrible job
messed up a bunch of stuff and then
ended up kind of going back home to live
with his family they're not really
sending their best and this is just
another example where again I would say
to you to Republicans are you so
committed to the party
that you would quite literally rather a
guy who goes home instead of doing the
job than a Democrat who cares and I know
the answer for many of them the answer
is yes
it's it's quite it's that simple and for
many of them especially the ones who say
our elected officials shouldn't even be
doing that much it's extra exciting to
see a guy go I'm not going to do
anything I'm just going home because
they don't want government doing stuff
so as insane as this is
you will find Defenders of Madison
cawthorne who will say I think it's good
he doesn't need to be there voting on
all sorts of stuff that government
shouldn't even be involved in he has
abandoned his job we'll have all of the
clips from all of these segments on our
Instagram which you can find at David
packman show we're going to take the
shortest of breaks and then the show
continues
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show it is
great to have Rick Sanchez joining us
today veteran journalist and Emmy Award
winner who is the co-founder CEO and
president of agua media Rick it's so
great to have you on
I'm listen um David I I
am so proud of you as a fellow Latino
everything you do uh your determination
your ability to always fight for the
little guy your consistency uh General
fairness your messaging uh you do a
great job David and and you ought to be
commended and I just got to be telling I
got to tell you with all transparency
I've been a fan for some time I've been
listening to what you do and you do a
really great job so there you go I'm
shocked and flattered but also it
provides like a really good segue into
when we think about the Dynamics of the
American
Spanish-speaking or Latino origin
Community there it's such a diverse
Community many people see me they say
David you look white how is it that
you're South America what's and of
course you and I and many people in our
community we know about the diversity
but politically it's also quite a
diverse group and as as I want to hear
from you the conventional wisdom is
often Cubans and Venezuelans they often
come to the U.S they become Republicans
because they see that as a way to fight
that which they left in their home
countries those from many other South
American countries in Central America
tend to be more democratic leaning is
that the is that still accurate today
I think to a certain extent it is
unfortunately it's overplayed so what
happens is like with the election with
Trump for example Trump did in fact you
know get his uh he gets credit for
winning Florida unfortunately he didn't
win Nevada he didn't win Texas he didn't
win anywhere else in the country 70 of
the people in the United States are not
Venezuelans or argentinians or Cubans
they are for the most part either
Mexican or from other parts of Central
America but that message gets lost David
so still uh the message seems to be that
all the Latinos are moving to the
Republican Camp
um and that's not true uh Latinos
continue to vote basically two-thirds uh
Democrat and one-third Republican and
that's changed a little bit over time
but it seems to me that the message
that's coming certainly from the right
the right is spending millions and
millions of dollars with Americano and
all these other front groups to try and
bring in and Sorrows for example to try
and bring in Latinos
they get credit for trying but
considering the amount of money they're
putting into it and considering how
little competition they're getting from
Democrats to try and keep Latinos there
they actually aren't doing that well I
wouldn't score them highly on that yeah
it's interesting because you often
touted is oh in 2020 Trump increased his
share of the Latino vote by eight
percent but when you start with a small
number even increasing it is not super
impressive but that being said if the
trend continued it actually would be
hugely significant
well sure and they even did well in this
last election if you want to go by uh
decimal points yeah and I think to a
certain extent look I mean let's just
call this what it is how much can
Latinos be told that they're rapists and
criminals by certain segments of the
Republican party like Cruella Deville
running for governor in Arizona and you
know after a while it's uh obviously
going to create a backlash the the
problem and I wish what I would see is
more David Pacman's and more Rick
Sanchez's and I'm not just trying to say
that we're the only ones that got this
thing figured out but I'd like to see
that on the NBCS and the cbs's and the
cnns and other places where they don't
just uh kowtow to Latinos and uh tell
you about how much they like you but
actually understand that we're the fifth
largest GDP in the world if we were a
country that 80 percent of us are
American citizens that uh uh 30 40 41 of
us uh under the age of 50 English as our
language none of these things are
proliferated so I I don't I think
both the Republican Party beating the
crap out of the Latinos uh and then the
Democratic party unfortunately not going
far enough to really represent or
understand Latinos almost even taking
them for granted to a certain extent
creates this Dynamic that we're in right
now and it's got to change on both sides
obviously one of the stories that's been
told in the political world for at least
10 years if not even longer is there's
these demographic shifts happening in
States like Florida and Texas and part
of it is age-related but a lot of it is
the growth of the Hispanic or Latino
population and it's just going to make
it difficult and eventually impossible
for Republicans to win Florida and Texas
and it hasn't played out and many people
are looking at the numbers and saying
okay is this happening is it what is it
going to play out what is happening with
that
well I think you have to take one thing
into account and this is maybe the most
important thing
Latinos the the common age of a Latino
David is 11. on say 11. that's the node
right scientifically speaking
mathematically speaking the common age
of a Latino is 11. lock that number in
because the common age of a uh a white
Anglo-Saxon non-latino in the United
States is 58.
so what that tells you is because
Latinos are young they're going to be
voting in the future more in line with
what we just saw some young people
voting in this last election so what
they're going to care about is not
like we hear today in parts of uh South
Florida but they're probably going to be
voting more in line with regular you
know American young people and that
would not bode well for the Republicans
but right now yeah Republicans have done
a great job in South Florida in
particular bringing into Venezuelan and
the Cuban vote and the others who come
from certain parts of Latin America by
telling them that if you vote Democrat
you're voting for Chavez you're voting
for Fidel Castro because all Democrats
are communists one of the things that
applies generally when it comes to
targeting young voters is that the right
seems much more committed financially to
setting up things like Turning Point USA
sending Ben Shapiro to college campuses
and paying handsome speaking
Etc you really don't see it as much on
on the left and it seems that the same
thing applies specifically to the
targeting of Latino voters where there's
lots of right-wing Spanish language
political content on the radio in the
United States but really not much
alternative to that
you know
one of the reasons I'm doing agua media
because it's really a bit of a passion
project for myself and for Solomon
Trujillo my partner
um you know Saul and I realized that if
we don't get the story out ourselves and
thank God we have a David Pacman who's
also a Latino who's also an influential
member of uh the media Community to be
able to tell the story that
unfortunately I wish MSNBC would tell
but they don't let's face it we're 20 of
the population in the United States and
we are underrepresented across the board
whether it's Hollywood or whether it's
on cable television Nancy Pelosi said
something interesting God love her and I
know she made a mistake and she's an
older woman and stuff and but she should
have known better soon after DeSantis
did this stunt where he literally
hijacked people or kidnap people and
sent them to another state from Texas
her response was what a shame because
imagine the farmers in Florida could
have used some of those immigrants for
example to pick their fruit and their
vegetables and I thought to myself Nancy
God bless you but that's not what you
say the answer is right now and in the
future Latinos will be the doctors the
business people they'll be the people
who create this unbelievable probably
enterprising economy of ours they tend
to hire more they tend to start more
small businesses you need to know that
Nancy when you talk about Latinos and
that's the problem and we don't get it
at CNN we don't get it at the msnbcs and
those are the ones who are supposed to
be our stalwarts and in that example and
it's not the beat up you know Nancy
Pelosi but yeah you know that's that's
the wrong message that's the wrong
counter to the other argument that's
important David and that's why you and I
guys like you and I are out there to
share these things well one thing I want
to ask you about and I have no idea what
your position is on this so I could be
stepping into a Minefield here is one of
the things that when you talk about the
conversation among the left and Latino
Americans has to do with the gender
neutralizing of the Spanish language and
I'm talking about Latin X and I'm taught
so that's in English Latin X and then
there's a movement in Spanish as well
where it would take something like the
word Amigos or Amigas which are gendered
and create a new one which is amiges
with an e now my view is this is a
really bad idea I don't think this makes
any sense most people in Central and
South America don't use that later
example I gave Latin X is mostly being
proposed by white Americans I think that
this if this becomes the thing that is
the topic in the US among the left with
this population I think it's a disaster
where where are you on that we're just
throwing the right a bone to be able to
use to coalesce Latinos against
Democrats and then they could go with
that woke thing that you know is so
amorphous and opaque I don't even know
what the hell it means but don't do that
don't I mean I'm so proud of my mother
for everything she gave to me as you are
of your mother and your mother is a
Latina and my mother is a Latina and my
father is a Latino I can't think of
describing Paco my dad as a latinx you
know know what does that mean to me
besides if you're going to do it with us
Latinos then you also have to do it with
Italians because they do use a
non-gender neutral uh you know language
because they all come from romance
languages and Romanians and the French
and every Portuguese and everything so
leave well enough alone as our as our
friend Willie Shakespeare said when it
comes to something like this and let's
tackle the really big issues that are
affecting Latinos in the United States
and not change their nomenclature it
just seems like a bridge too far it
almost seems like almost a little
insulting to me so when it comes to
latinx In fact when it comes to all
colorations I don't think we should be
brown I don't think we should be yellow
I don't think we should be black I think
you're an argentinian-american and I am
a cuban-american and my friend Jerry
over here who I'm looking at is a
Mexican-American and somebody can be a
Jamaican American or an irish-american
it's a better description in the old
days when you called someone a colored
person it was insulting and it seems
like today we want to bring that back
and somehow celebrate it I'm against
Colors Let's call each other as
descriptively as we can as we learned in
journalism school so that we understand
how people are described let's talk a
little bit about immigration and
specifically DACA
DACA to me seems like it would be the
lowest hanging fruit that both Democrats
and Republicans would be incentivized to
figure out and deal with and say okay
here's something we've fixed so it's not
just endlessly a quote crisis now of
course the term crisis is exaggerated
and it's used uh you know right leading
up to an election and then suddenly you
don't hear about it for a year we know
all of that stuff okay but on the DACA
issue it seems overwhelmingly popular to
say we're not going to send people back
to other countries who came here through
no fault of their own as minors with
parents why hasn't it happened is part
of it that neither side wants to allow
the other side to be able to take credit
for that I think to be honest with you
obviously Republicans have had a odd and
almost cruel view of that and have for
many many years with some exceptions uh
you know we we can give some credit to
to George Bush and we can give some
credit hell even to Lindsey Graham at
some point I don't know what the heck
happened to that guy there was a time
when he had a different way of thinking
about uh things like this yeah
um but unfortunately Democrats have
never really made this including you
know President Obama have never really
made this the priority that they that
they needed to make it to to to Really
make sure that they were uh
um you know uh making strides with the
Latino Community where it matters you
know right here you know as we like to
say
um and and that's you know I think to a
fault and and I think oftentimes
Democrats you know as I said in that
famous uh in that in that famous uh
documentary that Billy did uh you know
the thing about Democrats is they're
always trying to do the right thing and
please everybody and Republicans could
give a crap they just want to win so
Republicans don't care who they insult
and what they do as long as in the end
they can win uh that's kind of the
McConnell message right in many ways
which it's interesting now that they're
trying to kick him out and Democrats
instead have always kind of overplayed
things and be concerned about how it's
going to be seen and well if we come out
too heavy on this then we could lose
Middle America because we might lose
votes in the Midwest and they overthink
things so much and in the end they don't
do enough and I think if Democrats had
gotten on board DACA for example really
gotten on board
um I think they would be faring better
now and not fighting you know between 60
65 and 70 of the vote and and really
they would probably be topping out
around 80 because remember the people
that are affected by this especially are
are the people who are the larger part
of the Latino Community right the
Mexican-American and the Central
American part of the of those Latino
communities so it would make a huge
difference I think well hopefully we
will at least see some progress on that
at some point it may take Democrats
allowing Republicans to do it under
their watch to get that win and the
question is whether Democrats would go
for it because it's the right thing to
do even if they don't get all of the
political benefit
yeah yeah you know it's funny in this
last election I watched something happen
there was this guy who turned out to be
a pretty awful human being but for some
reason he and I used to talk a lot he
would call me at least once a week when
he was running Fox News and that's Roger
Ailes and he used to say to me and said
publicly in fact
that the funny thing about Republicans
is they don't tell you what they think
they just show up to uh to uh the
polling place and uh show their actions
with their vote and they don't go around
giving their opinions
wow what a difference between what just
happened in this election not just with
Latinos but with others Republicans are
now the hippies of the 1970s they're the
ones having parades they're the ones
putting it out there there I mean I
would never go screaming down the middle
of the street holding a banner of any
candidate we're putting bumper stickers
all over my house and doing all of those
things and that's what you see now with
with with Republicans and and you invite
them over to your backyard barbecue and
he happens to be your neighbor and he's
Republican and immediately starts
telling you who who's going to vote for
who he hates and you're like okay here
you want a beer it's the weirdest it's
the weirdest thing that's interesting
why are you telling me this and uh that
used to be what Democrats were kind of
like in the 60s and 70s now Democrats
just keep their mouths shut they wait
and when it comes to vote they voted
against it and that's kind of what we
saw in this last midterm and it made me
think of the flip that baby happened in
our society yeah and Roger rails
captured the quiet Republican and
created a television network for them
right and brought them out to the point
now where they're I guess they're loud
and proud but not effective right
they're not quiet anymore that's for
sure no no that I mean that that's the
point it's almost like it's a
counterintuitive or ironically different
we've been speaking with Rick Sanchez
who's the co-founder CEO and president
of agua media Rick really a pleasure
having you on
it's a pleasure to be with you as well
David thanks so much and uh you know
vamos Dali
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
we have a very important runoff election
happening in Georgia on December 6th it
is Herschel Walker versus incumbent
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock this
will not decide who controls the Senate
Democrats will control the Senate but it
will decide do Democrats control 50 50
with Kamala Harris as the tie-breaking
vote or do Democrats control 5149 making
Kamala Harris unnecessary or creating a
little bit of margin in case Joe manchin
or Kirsten Cinema decide not to play
ball well as I've told you before
Herschel Walker the Republican candidate
is one of the most if not the most
unqualified candidate for the Senate I
can ever remember covering I've played
Four you times where Herschel Walker has
been incoherent where he's been visibly
disoriented where he has said nonsense
gobbledygook coming out of his mouth
all of those examples are nothing
compared to what I'm going to play for
you today
Herschel Walker
speaking a mile a minute I've never seen
this before this is upper Herschel
Walker on a rant about werewolves and
vampires that I challenge you I
challenge you
to make through the entire thing
listen to this I want you to keep the
faith
oh do you ever watch a stupid movie late
at night hoping going to get better
don't get better but you keep watching
it anyway because other night the other
night I was watching this movie I was
watching this movie called Fright Night
Freak night or some type of night but
it's about vampires I don't know if you
know vampires and cool people are they
not but I'm gonna tell you something
that I found out a werewolf can kill a
vampire did you know that I never knew
that so I didn't want to be a vampire
anymore I want to be a werewolf but then
anyway elect this man watching this
movie and then you tell you how stupid
it is because it's one in the morning so
I'm watching my TV of these kids
watching their TV uh vampire kill on
their TV
so you know it's kind of stupid but I'm
still watching though as I'm watching
this show what was funny these kids had
a vampire in that attic at their house
so they were watching their TV
now I'm watching my TV they're watching
their TV this is sad right is the sadder
crazier scary I don't know I mean I
think the scary part is that this guy
might be a senator
see if I killed on that TV so they win
this contest to bring this actor now
y'all gotta stay with me bring this
actor who's a Vampire killer from that
TV to get rid of this real life vampire
in that Attic So if this actor comes to
their home he got all the right stuff he
got all the right stuff because you know
I gotta have a state and got to have a
thing to kill him in the heart and he
got a necklace of garlic could that work
is anybody still with us here I don't
know what it does but it worked we gotta
have a cross because it burned I know
that worked and then all of a sudden
this is what was so funny about it and
they're walking through the house this
these this this guy's got the holy water
he blessing the house this actor now
he's all fake he's dressed in the house
with his holy water they walked upstairs
and this vampire looking real good in
this black suit whoa that sounds like
Senator or not doesn't it look you know
all good in this black suit floating I
guess that's the connection to the
campaign from the ceiling he floated
from the ceiling good and cool and I'm
thinking whoa they better get out of
that house and somebody float from your
ceiling get out of that house that's
that's not your house but as he floated
from the ceiling the kid jumped behind
that hero as they jump behind that hero
the guy jumped in front of this holy
water Threw It On The Vampire forehead
he covered his eye
then he took his hand away we're almost
through it and the reason I'm playing
the whole thing is for you to realize
this was not just 10 seconds out of
context this was a two-minute
unintelligible hopped up rant he started
laughing and he said that don't work he
took the cross he put it on the vampire
forehead and the vampire didn't even do
anything he said that don't work and
that's where it is in our life it ain't
working unless you got faith it is time
for us to have faith we got to have
faith in our fellow brother we got to
have faith in this country got to have
faith in this in the elected officials
and right now that's the reason I'm here
does anybody understand why he's there I
don't I'm from that explanation he says
that's why I'm here
I don't understand why he's there
folks do you understand the level of
Despair that we should all feel at the
state of democracy if this man can
become an American Senator a United
States Senator one of 100 Senators it is
extra important that we do everything we
can
to prevent him from becoming a senator
this is a humiliation this I quite I'm
not exaggerating okay
if I walked into guys I don't know a dry
cleaner if I walked into anywhere an
accounting firm and they said uh CPA
Walker is going to be handling your
taxes this year
and people the whoever comes in speaks
like this rants like this about things
I'm not hiring that person
and he's on the cusp of becoming a U.S
senator when Raphael Warnock understands
the issues
seems reasonably empathetic seems to
understand the process of the Senate I
mean what are we even talking about here
here's one more clip from this where
it's something about bicycles I I don't
even know it's it's wow but what we need
to do is get rid of those 87 000 RS
agents that's going to go after you
maybe we need to push now remember there
aren't 87 000 IRS or Ras agents that
it's just it's not true
remember that over the next decade 55
000 IRS agents will retire so there's a
plan to replace them with 55 000 new IRS
agents in addition the IRS is
understaffed so there's going to be a
slight increase to Staffing and in terms
of them going after people this is the
armed IRS agent's thing there's like a
very small division in the IRS I don't
remember if it's a couple hundred or at
the most like 1800 something like that
agents who carry firearms and like they
they are they are police at the end of
the day and police carry firearms
police officer and I was stood protect
our kids that's what we need to do
that's what we need to do but yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah we got people in
Washington that got into weak all they
want to do is let people ride that bike
that's what Senator wanted to do is then
Joe Biden ride his bike because he voted
with him 96 of the time which means he
don't know what he's doing or he seem to
love Joe Biden I don't know which one it
is I can tell you both of them is wrong
it's it's really sad at the end of the
day I mean it just he doesn't make any
sense this is this is the embodiment of
everything we should be working really
hard to keep out of public office it's
it's everything it's everything it's
personal hypocrisy a personal history of
not being a particularly good person
completely ignorant on the issues I mean
there there is no checklist of things we
should try to keep out of public office
that doesn't include everything that
Herschel Walker is so let's make sure if
you vote in Georgia make sure you
understand where and when to vote there
is a lawsuit currently about early
voting if you can plan to vote on
December 6th plan to vote on December 6
we will be live with
um election results and all of it on
that day I want to briefly talk about
Ivanka Trump many of you emailed me
about this story Ivanka Trump is
refusing to be involved with Donald
Trump's 2024 run now she is putting a
very positive spin on it there is an
article in the cut which summarizes this
called Ivanka would prefer not to the
article is by Claire lampin it was
published yesterday and it includes a
transcript of ivanka's Instagram post
where she said
um I love my father very much
this time around I'm choosing to
prioritize my young children and the
private life we are creating together as
a family I do not plan to be involved in
politics while I will always love and
support my father going forward I will
do so outside the political Arena I am
grateful to have had the honor of
serving the American people and I will
always be proud of many of our
administration's accomplishments
listen
um this has been a building Fiasco for
Jared and Ivanka and I have to say you
know this isn't about I think ivanka's
great but it has always struck me that
from the adult children and I include
Jared Kushner in this as the son-in-law
that Ivanka most accurately had the
pulse
uh
understood the pulse of what the
perception of trump and his kids was and
we had numerous reports when Trump's
term was waning and it was you know he
had lost already he was claiming he was
going to figure out a way to stay but it
was obvious he was leaving there were
these reports about how Jared and Ivanka
were struggling with the fact that their
old Social Circles were refusing they
were they were not welcoming them back
in and there were a bunch of different
stories that you can find about this and
then in the lead up to Donald Trump's
announcement on Tuesday night there was
also reporting about Trump has been
begging Jared and Ivanka to be there and
it's not clear whether they are going to
be there and at the end of the day
Ivanka wasn't there and Jared Kushner
was I actually respect this more than
anything I've ever seen Ivanka do of
course she was in way over her head even
being involved with this Administration
she had no business there remember when
she sat in for then Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson at like the G something
Summit it's all completely and utterly
insane but the most responsible and
respectful uh uh thing that Ivanka has
done here is to recognize this was a
humiliation and hey you know what she
values her personal life she values her
social life she realizes that it was
humiliating what happened I am sure that
she still thinks that good things were
done by her dad I don't I don't think
she thinks it was a disaster but she
increasingly recognizes the cartoonish
nature of what went on around the
January 6 riots there are reports that
Ivanka was horrified by what was going
on and wasn't thrilled with Donald
Trump's response so
I understand why she's not just coming
out and saying this was a complete
humiliation to my my personal family
right her and her kids
there is probably all sorts of crazy
stuff going on in terms of her versus
Jared because for now it seems that
Jared is standing behind Trump although
it increasingly seems like he's not go
he would not be a part of an upcoming
Trump Administration this actually is
the most logical thing I've ever heard
of Ivanka doing she should have no
involvement it's been a humiliation it's
been bad for her it's obviously terrible
for her kids
and this is clearly the right decision
so good for Ivanka I think it makes
sense and the question now remains
uh what's Jared going to do on a
personal level I don't care but it is
interesting to see the difference
between Eric and Don Jr who are clearly
Full Speed Ahead on this and Ivanka who
seems a little bit more reflective and
thoughtful about the disaster that this
has been for their family we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
David P you know one thing I've learned
in doing this show homophobic people
don't like being called homophobic take
a listen to this
hi David I'm calling from Decatur
Georgia
you're not watch this show regularly and
um anytime someone doesn't agree with
the
homosexual lesbian
transgender lifestyle you call them
transphobic
homophobic
and I think that's wrong people have a
right to their own beliefs
and I think it should stop labeling
people
as having a phobia
because they disagree with their
lifestyle
you should probably check yourself out
on that thank you listen
the mere use of the word lifestyle is
already problematic homophobes that I've
been interviewing for more than a decade
love to talk about the gay lifestyle and
that is a flag that you are homophobic
now I think it's important to understand
that when we use the term homophobic and
transphobic a lot of people like to play
the kind of literal semantic games where
they go it's not a phobia I just think
it's wrong this is similar to when
people when they hear the phrase
anti-Semitism they go why is the word
anti-Semitism semites also include
people of Arab descent not just Jews
right but Google the term anti-Semitism
the term anti-Semitism even though the
etymology relates to Semite is related
specifically to anti-jewish sentiment
and similarly when we talk about
homophobia and transphobia we don't
literally mean I'm afraid it's a phobia
it is more all-encompassing than that so
so not a shock homophobes and
transphobes don't like to be called that
we're going to have a fantastic bonus
show today we'll talk about the FTX
collapse we will talk about lab-grown
meat being cleared for human consumption
and we will talk about over a billion
young people being at risk for hearing
loss something that I have much to say
about sign up at joinpakman.com don't
miss today
thank you